yeah hello and welcome to this video
yeah this is the video about all the
games that I had played recently where
the videos had no sound yeah big
disappointed disappointment for me
invested quite a bit of time in
recording those it's 30 games in total
and they all have no sound if I have the
videos they have no sound and what I
decided to do is simply to put all those
games into a DTS study here and discuss
some of them highlights or discuss some
of the more interesting games maybe some
key points of the games I felt uploading
the games without any sound would be a
little bit odd I was thinking about it
but I think I'm just picking out some
good moments out of the games and
explaining them is more useful to just
put the games out with no sound and
dubbing them afterwards it's just an
enormous amount of time that I mean I
wasn't really sure how to do it I mean
add some ideas how to do it but it's
lots of work and I basically want to
invest time and getting new good videos
done but I also don't want to simply
yeah ignore those 30 games and there
were some interesting moments for sure
so let's get right into it um I have the
games here loaded into DJ's study and
I've sorted them probably in the wrong
water right I'm starting with the most
recent games but um it doesn't really
matter all that much the videos are not
released anyway so let's get let's get
rolling I have 30 games in total so I
won't remember every single detail but
when I see the rough outline of the
Moose I'll be able to tell you what what
were the key points so let's start
that's the first game
when I was actually black so I can
switch colors and playing here that was
played to Dave and I've got a head black
in the game and we had a default least
64 Bishop before check this is a kind of
an BOGO Indian but without the knight
being out on f6 this adds some
interesting twists as we see in this
game I got into a position where I went
to play e5 here and we had a closed
position now with Knight not being on f6
I have additional ideas to play a five
in one go without moving the night
that's quite interesting after Bishop b3
airplane h6 preventing any Knight g5
moves for example if f5 is happening
then this is very awkward yeah I got the
engine lines here so you can see what
the engine is doing by the way all the
games if they are I played them only
chess for but for a couple of reasons
but one reason is that every single game
you can access in ditches if you go into
my profile and you go into games you can
absolutely replay all of the games or
download them if you want so you have a
much better access to those games
compared to me playing those games on
different platforms so ok here F 5 was
bad so at age 6 and our opponent
surprised we were playing 9 th 4 which
leaves this night hanging and I decided
to challenge him on that so now the
knight was attacked discovered attacked
and after the capture Queen takes what
actually has very decent compensation
for the pawn he has the idea to play
quick f4 and open up the position for
his Bishop so it would have been
interesting but my opponent surprised me
with nitrogen 6 pretty we
can be Caza move this night is going to
be taken any way I can snatch yet
another pawn and then I take on g6 and
him my position is a lot better
I've got two extra pawns and g5 was
designed to stop F form and then the
position is more or less clearly winning
two pawns is a bit too much and the only
interesting moment a little bit later
was here when my opponent took one c5
and this does not really work but you
have to be precise take take and now
Knight to f4 is a good move the text
book covers the bishop and the Texas
Bishop and that is too much in one goal
he should have taken on g7 I think this
is a bit bit tougher instead he took on
e6 and resigned one move later but if he
takes on g7 you can imagine a sequence
like that and yeah at least have to find
yeah I mean I probably management I have
to find this one Queen therefore I have
two pieces up so I can easily return one
and now I'm threatening Quincy one maid
and win yeah in the game it took me six
and after the recapture it was just a
win with the rook up and he resigned to
him
so I'm guessing a decent opening line by
the way this bishop before check if you
don't mind to play one in six which
invites the French then one is six as he
would reply okay then the second came
here yeah there for some was an English
opening we can jump right to this
position
oops this position after d4 if you look
at this he played a Kings Indian set up
against my English and I was very happy
with this position because White's
pieces are much better coordinated
they're all somewhat geared towards the
center while the knight on
six and the night only aids they both
look a little bit odd
he played Knights who before and now
after this sequence we simplified the
position but the main issue is that d6
is a weak pawn on an half-opened file
and black it really has no compensation
for that in the game he later tried to
break out with d5 like that but then
ultimately lost the bond and the
resulting ending is favorable for wild
like a lot not just because of the pawn
which is very useful but also because of
the advantage in space and g6 weakness I
think it became entirely lost once he
decided to play a six and that is giving
me yet more to play against b7 pawn yeah
this is a winning ending I did not
really play it in the fastest possible
way but I kept a really sizable
advantage and managed to at the end
winders here there is a a little bit of
an interesting moment he took on a four
it would have been interesting to see
okay for being played but the key point
is that he can take with the rook and
rook takes does not work because King
basics check check picks up this rook it
was important he took on f4 and now I
got to pick up the airport and my pawn
is just a lot quicker so I wanted this
endgame pretty easily
at the end um yeah there was a very
typical game for the English opening to
get structures like that quite
frequently if you play this often okay
this was a black game some new to switch
colors yeah this had some interesting
moments I don't want to look at the
opening all that much this one's not an
interesting moment when you look at this
position here white has just checked on
d5 and during the game I saw that after
Bishop e6 F takes
88 the Queen is queen is trapped during
the game I actually did not spot that is
7 now is just good after Luke takes
Queen I capture takes he has excellent
an excellent position he's got two
bishops and look for the Queen which is
of course fantastic I actually did not
see seven I was only thinking even after
some normal more of it yeah like nothing
special and I take here and this I
already felt was a bit weird to play
again so I avoided that I played King
and eight if they droop d1 and TNF a
group D aid was a strong move which
somehow I missed I'm not quite sure why
maybe I was so focused on not playing
against the Queen I don't know
I played Bishop the same group the 88
was strong he has to do this then and
it's not really clear that White has
some chances to fight in this position
I'm probably just a lot better yeah I
played Bishop to b7 and we got a
position way I wonder upon and
yeah later I miss plated and we got to
Luke ending which was better for black
but not necessarily winning and then we
had a funny situation it continued and
and he somehow managed to find a way to
to kill himself and this was here he of
course you have to go look a8 and go
back to keep an eye on that pawn as long
as the rook is attacking a - I cannot
move my a1 rook and then promote as a2
is hanging and there is no check of
course for me that makes any sense with
the look this is just a drawing I can
try to maneuver with the king but
whenever I go forward this going to be a
check and he managed to play rook c8 and
after King to b7 it's over he cannot
prevent this this was really funny
because he had some time left I remember
I'm not sure if this is on this
sub-discipline here but he had time left
I remember that quite quite clearly and
yeah now I got the Queen and wonders
wonders quite quickly the our Queen
against rook is fairly easy win anyway
and especially against a human player
you will very often end up like that
where you just pick up the room it's
extremely difficult to prevent the
simple awesome okay next game in psyche
that was not very exciting and this guy
is very high rated - 6:30 I played the
petrov and we got this Bishop e7 low and
where I get to trade those bishops and I
think once black is there like in this
position you have excellent chance is to
draw against almost anybody because the
position
has very little tension it's very little
that white can play for some sort of
non-symmetrical idea that makes some
mumps make something happen in the game
nothing much happened really it was a
huge trade fest the only thing is like
the ending I got was actually quite nice
and there was one particular situation
that I want to point out here I decided
to take on a form and it would have been
really better to play before after
before Black has quite good chances
really to play for more than the draw I
did not want to place that on a dark
square but it keeps on some important
squares like c3 under control and
generally speaking in space I have some
chances to try to play for when was g4
and an age for and I have got a little
bit more space and ideas to improve its
so very likely draw but I could have
tried and in the game after the capture
it was system very equal ish yeah the
Petrov is a super solid defense if you
play in a strong player with black and
you are totally fine with the solid
position the Petrov is excellent okay
the next game that was against Louise
Michelle very difficult name for me and
this was a classical Dutch and I played
the move before forgetting my prep I
actually played b3 and I think it's a
good line for what and I'd already see
that black can equalize against it at
all
but however I forgot it and I played
before and some moves later black
surprised me by playing that too
seven and this was actually after this
sequence leading to trouble because
before is attacked twice
you only have D 5 to cover it and after
the capture and Queen B 3 this situation
here at text before and he cannot take
it
he cannot cover it I'm sorry after night
here I just take this and a big pawn up
and and I went one to win this game
quite quickly
yeah the classical Dutch is not an
opening I would recommend if you play it
and somehow it works out for you okay
you can do it but there's very little
incentive to pick it up I think there
are too many problem variations okay the
next game plan against Jin Zhu Dipper
we had a Russell Nemo and the game
bought down to one particular situation
here I think white is a little bit more
comfortable if you check the details the
bishop on g7 doesn't look all that great
and I played rookie 4 in this position
and I remember that during the live
commentary that was lost at the end I
was saying that ok he has to go back
maybe to d5 and then we'll see what
happens and I mentioned that Queen takes
b2 does not work due to Knight to c4 and
the Queen is trapped and in fact after a
couple of seconds Bush he took it and
after night c4 the queen is indeed
trapped
it only has c3 or before and in both
cases Bishop 22 were cut off every
single possible escape square so he took
on a1 and I wasn't cleaned up and
wonders easily he of course should not
have taken on b2 but rather go back
maybe to d5 and then I'm not sure what I
would have done I
I envisioned something like that to
happen and um I feel like right it's a
little bit better here that main reason
is that those central squares g6e 67
that tend to be weak and Misha pair is
not super relevant as both blacks
bishops don't do all that much okay um
any at this game yeah that was also
[Music]
basically decided in the opening I play
the Sicilian Kalashnikov fear with black
and white when neither three which is
not very critical the reason is that
black gets this easy development and
with the bishop coming to be too it's
it's like a temple move you have to
think about those threats probably best
in this position for white is to play
Bishop c4 simply and go for developing
yeah this was already comfortable and a
little bit later he made a mistake after
before I took on c3 and he of course
white has to check on a file after which
Green takes a five leads to a position
where black is a pawn up but the game
continues I'm a lot better but it just
continues and he instead after D takes
c3 it took on d8 probably overlooked
then I can take with the bishop and save
it so I was a piece of for nothing much
and he resigned a couple of most Lehner
so we're basically in opening win okay
the next game against Bonita which was
even shorter
we had wire transposition we had a
philidor's defense and people are not
aware of that so much but this position
is already quite good for white it
normally would not arise from a ninety a
three bit from d4 d5 9 3 d 64 best move
the 7 Bishop c4 Bishop c4 as an
important move because this is really
putting notice
into question whatever black does he is
in some trouble the relatively best
choice but rarely played because it does
not fit very well with 97 is to take on
deform sorry it's a check on d4 which is
only a slight edge for white like Queen
D 494 both inside Vantage just have more
space and so on but black is not getting
killed immediately and after many moves
after Bishop c4 he will be killed
immediately one of them is Bishop e7
that's what was playing the game even
worse is this move this is a very funny
variation that leads to winning attack
for white for example I discussed all
those lines in my e4 keep it simple
repertoire releases on chasuble it's
really not not too bad to look at those
ones I know it looks obscured the moment
maybe if you get this on the board all
the time in the game you played Bishop
e7 after which I take and now if you
would have taken with the night you get
this where this double attack wins the
big e5 pawn like g6 and white is a lot
better here ever recaptured with the
pawn which after Queen d5 prompted
resignation immediately f7 is lost and
well but what what do you do now we have
no decent move like it's just totally
lost so winning in six movies is nice
ok the next game I had black again Sakia
Sochi I don't know and it was a closed
variation of the of the rule no pass and
that was interesting
when we jumped to move 20 and I should
switch the perspective icon gained a bit
of space I got the 65 d5 define and I
was quite happy with my position 11 now
white played an odd newly played Queen
f3
I went King edge 7
to prepare g6 until excited to go back
that was a bit odd and now here creator
d8 would have been a very strong move I
did not think about the center or
created d8 it's difficult because it's a
retreat to the square and cream was
originally being positioned now it looks
sorry that was wrong it looks at H 4
which means that G 6 threatens now to
win the night and what has a big of a
problem a bit of a problem here to
prevent that but you know what can you
do you can for example go back here but
it doesn't help all that much I have c4
I've got rook c8 Queen d8 what would be
a strong move I played rook 88 so
decentralizing and after Bishop c106
Knight back and c4
I had a huge initiative on the Queen
side and it led to a very good position
that was yeah very good as a bit of an
understatement I had a really almost
winning position but there was a really
cool movement a little bit later
I wonder d5 pawn rook e1 and now I
should have taken on c3 just take the
pawn it's a temple which is important
attacking this and white only has very
awkward moves to address that like King
to f1
I played Bishop g7 11 after 94 the
knight got activated and now after the
move Knight b3 Knight f6 take cake in
fact this was a text and that was
something that I did not really
recognize beforehand that I have to
spend now and move the tempo to come f7
I played Queen to c7 and that turned out
to be a grave mistake if you would have
now found the correct continuation
however I feel it's a very difficult
move to
here the move Bishop f4 would have
totally annihilated me I cannot take it
which is quickly checked when
threatening mate in two variants for two
ways and it's just lost just lost I
cannot take it but at the same time he
threatening Bishop takes d5 and then to
make me here my king is a little bit a
little bit a little bit weakened my king
position usually a fool was winning was
just winning after Bishop e3 I managed
to get the knight back into the game and
here I got everything saved and won
quite quickly so I was a lucky one
next game here against basquiat scheme
[Music]
yeah that was a scotch for Knights wear
black decided to take and play d6 this
some kind of setup where black is going
for a d6 based approach is always better
for white simply because of space and
just ease of the play it's so easy now
for me to play a few of helicopters like
here I got this f3 long castle set up
and then you push g4 and attack on the
King side
it's absolutely unclear what blacks
counter players he's got no clear pawn
storm and move like c6 would weaken d6
pawn not very difficult to give him some
advice black played 97 in this moment
and whence f4 and expected him to play
Knight to c6 after knight c6 the Queen
moves I must be better quite clearly
because of those pawns a huge space
advantage but that would have been
better than his choice he took on g4 and
that does not work at all because I can
take and play
jiwon and there is this enormous
pressure on g7 so the bishop cannot meet
after age five age three and five
previously I was a piss-up and one
wonders quite quickly nothing much
happened hurricane in the next game I
got black save the perspective I could
have yeah anyway I could have been done
that with her with her with a key
yeah played a Caro and we had a fairly
typical current position I was quite
happy here White had castled and EH pond
looked like more of a richness than
anything else
so nothing specially played h5 and went
between to h4 I'm a bit behind in
development but the position is pretty
nice the d5 Knight is very stable
quite quite comfortable he played 95
which I decided to take there should be
71 and one thing that I absolutely did
not have on the radar is that white now
had the intention to play rook to deform
trapping my queen it is with hindsight
extremely obvious but I did not have it
on the radar at all
I played Bishop g5 and then got hit by
rock defiant it was an absolute
coincidence that I actually have the
move Queen takes g3 now otherwise I
would lose immediately but critics g3 is
in fact quite nice for black the way the
game went he took the Queen I'm just
winning I've got two minor pieces plus a
rope and there is no concrete problem
inside so this was something that would
have won
or that they'd won the game quite
quickly he in fact after Quinta xg3
he should have played differently
probably Luke takes d5 and here after
Bishop takes root III I am definitely
better but White has a good chance of
writing yeah something like Queen here
who takes Queen g5 or Crete c5 I don't
know what the best squares maybe have
similar I don't know I'm I'm a product
but things are not all that easy in the
game I got all those minor pieces and it
just it's just an excellent position you
just get to blow Kate the Kings side and
then step by step get a piece
coordination in and pick up pick up all
the pawns he resigned
it's no fun Bishop f4 is coming in I'm
ready to take off everything simply okay
and then I played this game against
passwords yeah there was a fairly fairly
clear win I played again I played the
petro put black and white played this
early c4 move which is actually quite
interesting but I don't think that
dangerous after Bishop before check yes
we move it twice but right now it does
not have anything super great available
he played King f1 which is the most
interesting move and probably the
intention of the whole line but we have
to check different things if he takes
this decision Knight goes out I can
develop and whites play is not that is
you have lots of active pieces and the
probly trade down more and be okay after
King I have one on castles c5 c6 White
King position was a little bit iffy on
everyone not that I can meet him but it
disturbs the coordination quite a bit on
the other hand the bishop on
a little bit weak yeah the way it turned
out
I got my pieces out easily and with b6 I
managed to attack his pawn chain
something like that proved to be an
excellent for black and yeah I wondered
fairly fairly easily later yeah jump
yeah I got this got the strong attack on
a3 so it was a fairly straightforward
win okay and then I got white against
each sly 82 and that was an accelerated
strengthen we had a fairly normal
looking position up to a certain point
after here after here here I was quite
happy with my position I thought I
should be a little bit better my pieces
are a bit more active than g7 Bishop is
not doing all that much
he played however now the surprising
move Knight to a5 and this is an
instructive moment the night comes to 85
to attack my b3 Bishop which is of
course a nuisance but what leg did not
take into account is that I have a
couple of technical solutions now
because the 1985 adds quite a bit of
looseness of to Black's position I
decided to play Bishop and form the
alternative rook takes a 7 was also very
decent after twin takes 95 and then i b6
was check to follow
why does winning the pawn and has a good
position on top this year forever it's
not bad either the Queen doesn't have
much choice it has to take and then we
get into the seventh rank and d5 is
totally unprotected and I won that one
yeah it was fairly fairly nice for me I
took
96 just trade oops I'm sorry just to
trade
he took my porn and I managed to get to
this position and here after King age 7
I think I am slightly better for sure
maybe he'd be clearly better but it's
just it's a game but he took on me too
when I played rookie six which was a
funny move because I was cursing myself
for blundering the rook yeah
Queen takes and an old was my crew he
did not play that and correctly so
because after it's heaven I will I will
promote it's a really really Ricky Ricky
position I can promote there's no way
for him to get to yeah eight with the
rookie I can check them then he doesn't
have access to you want because the
knight is there sorry the night of step
it's really weird so Ruby is six I was
really thinking I blended but it didn't
and after quite a bit of time spent he
shocked me by taking d5 which is of
course not working at all because of
rupee a check yeah so I won this one
this game then I had white against opium
I don't quite remember this game I do
remember the game okay but before I go
into I switch
yeah this is a game that I really am was
not enjoying all that much
he took here on Sephora in the slough
and played 25 Bishop d7 this is a setup
that is considered to be quite incorrect
you have to see that I have not yet
committed to anything ever played g3 I
have not played 2 c1 bishop he has not
played in 6 so I can go in 4 and this is
a nice position it is very much
comparable to a Marin variation but
there is no knight on c3 and that is
some nice thing to have
I hope didn't played well I played
Bishop b3 a6 castle 27 and here instead
of my move Bishop g5 I should have
played a 4 and after that White has a
comfortable game he cannot easily play
c5 because b 5 this under fire it is
probably a bit better for white I'm not
sure about the extent of the advantage
but it's comfortable
I went Bishop g5 age six was played I
went back but should be 797 and black
played c5 and here I was really annoyed
in myself I really remember that very
vividly because I rather quickly took on
c5 I should have taken on f6 with the
bishop that is a far more principled
continuation after Knight takes I went
upon and this is probably a rather clean
pawn I'm threatening before to cover it
form for a long time and he has no real
way a real way to prevent it so this is
very good better is to play G takes
after I got ideas like d5 which leads to
unclear play I should have taken on f6
that was a lot stronger I took on c5 and
after Knight takes I recognized that
formerly plans or earlier planned
version f6 is actually not helping
because it can take with
on can't even get attacking ideas on the
GFR the way it went I was okay but it
was not easy to play and he played it
very nicely with King f8 here for
example and then when he form he my
position isn't in huge trouble
there was a nicely played game by black
in the event of the game here I was yes
facing Bishop takes f3 and Bishop before
and yeah I read I fell into Bishop
before then I mean both you could really
do anything great but that was giving
away material and the game quite quickly
the next game on here got black against
ammaji that switch sides
yeah okay I remember that game it was a
I played a somewhat unconventional
opening with d6 of g6 and white played a
fairly slow ish Queen Colin opening it
was one moment was interesting that was
here when I got in c5 I mean I think the
engine assesses the position is equal
and one such a on c5 in order to play
Bishop deform next but white obviously
not an engine but a human played the
moves Knight f6 which i think is a
mistake I get to take it and put the
bishop en now the resulting structure is
not that nice I think like it's quite
comfortable even more so after he
allowed me to play c4 when there is c3
Queen need a - yeah lots of things
threatened yeah in the game as snatched
those pawns and managed to wind quite
easily that's sweet playing here black
against impassive yeah that was
interesting we had an Italian game very
normal disposition and here white is
most of the time like in this general
position tight I'm not talking about
this position in particular it's playing
slow maneuvers rook e1 but should be 3
things like that but why 20 deform and I
was happy about it because now after
taking NT 5 I get a structural even
balance
I expect expected him to capture and
felt that this is probably roughly equal
he played Bishop d3 either you know
there was a funny moment because during
the game a song that I can take on a
deform then after Knight takes take this
and now everything is hanging and I'm
getting a piece back which means I will
be material up and I'm taking stuff to
balls and then however I thought wait
why why so complicated I can just take
on e4 first and then take only deform
and while I was playing that I was
totally missing that in the sequence
Knight f6 Queen f6 94 that I cannot take
due to this this is a very typical motif
on the D farm and I was extremely lucky
that white didn't do that because it's a
totally frost line and I'm just a piece
down instead he took on d4 after which I
can take and I saw that one like this
happened or didn't happen like if he
would have taken on f6
take with the Queen and I have a
comfortable position with the pawn now
it's not an easy win because they look
on a7 is so awkward which it's about
white plate astonishing with rook see
one in order to play this and now the
engine says I should just take B - of
course yeah greeting greet greedy
can pay off but I felt that this is just
good 25 the rook has to take Bishop f5
and here we got to an ending that is
very nice very nice for black it's just
a pawn
and offered to trade and I slowly
improved the position gaining some space
and now the rook on d4 is having a
really nice position
a4 is weekend after rook before b2 is
also weak and very shortly afterwards
you know I had resigned after losing
losing all of the pawns and now I'm
getting the exchange back and ever can't
coordinating with three extra pawns
okay got this there was also yeah there
was a game that I really really really
that's one of those where when the
commentary being lost is really annoying
because it was a it was an entertaining
commentary for sure white win 93 against
Petrov and I went back to have six not a
bad line not the most principled one but
it's not too bad
yeah what why did you he went for short
oh sorry for long castling against this
line and this is not a good decision
black with b5 gets a really quick attack
but should be 305 and I'm sorry yeah so
we have a situation of a pawn race on
opposite side with water black is quite
quickly I went before nightly flow
Knight to d5 securing this excellent
square and he played this one and six
gave the check and after King f8 it's
almost the point of no return admittedly
but still it took on f7 which is
entirely incorrect I mean that does not
work in the slightest bit he sacrificed
yet another bishop
but after page 8 this is quite clearly
refuted you will lose more stuff that g5
check after King m8 and those pieces are
completely am Gabrielli positioned sorry
keep hitting the wrong button you played
Bishop to g6 I took the bishop on f7 and
here's a mysterious thing I saw that
Bishop g5 will win quite easily
yeah I'm simply pinning the Queen but
somehow I felt like if you takes here
take takes some I felt it's not so clear
I mean but I am piece up for two points
he's got no attack after King g7 in fact
I'm winning extremely easily yeah I
don't know I was seeing some ghosts they
have it
I played Quincy Quincy soon it is still
good for black from in the whole thing
but it is not easy to play and after
King b1 King to g7 takes Bishop iam you
checked me and now red rook to e1 this
is a winning for black if you let the
engine player it is not so simple it was
simply a simple to play for human and
after Knight a6 and Bishop tb7 the
situation was becoming not all that
clear here Bishop d2 was still good but
then the thing is you have to see little
things like here you have to see the
Morsi fire before that this is a huge
diagonal and it's not so easy to play
this move because the bishop only 7 was
kind of a user spectator the whole time
yeah I miss that one and after Knight f6
and queen d3 like here most like g5 they
are easy attacking needs and I just got
back down there just
just got totally wiped out yeah it was a
bit of a shame because well I am never
really a fan of somebody sacrificing
material against me that does not work
at all and I mean this is a kind of
thing if you see that it is like by
intuition totally obvious and it cannot
work I mean it never can work I mean if
I really thought it would work he has a
weird concept or with idea on attacking
just because this can only work if you
have some let's say on that part of the
board you have some sort of material
majority and you have some kind of
material dominance active pieces whatnot
but I have a couple of defenders and I
have not weakened my position at all
so that can never work but somehow and
didn't manage to get this yeah get this
sorted out next one year that was a
white game against a leap or that was
yeah that was very interesting actually
we got this position I was quite happy
and white has a favorable french-thai
position and I think we should see to
and he took on g3 and I was happy to
take with the F pawn to get the F file
half-opened yeah white has everything
geared towards the king saud he played
this and now shockingly played c4 which
was ready I was like what your closing
down the position while you're getting
checkmated on the other side of the
board okay I played g4b for g5 9 h 5
only move otherwise it's opening up
immediately I went night h4 which is
still fine g6 ok one to take you should
be three and here I could have wiped out
like and I didn't do it look f6 here was
extremely strong just to double this it
is absolutely irrelevant that
taking something here after f1 the f1
black is collapsing like rook here you
can already sacrifice you just have an
enormous dominance that say of attacking
pieces too far too many while we win him
in the game I played rugby 1 preventing
and it should be true and I Colin a nice
looking position but it did not really
turn out to be all that great he managed
to trade and after even more trades this
was a fairly equal ending and it was
equal up to this point here black should
play and yeah well basically play
whatever yeah just don't do what what he
did and f5 and that is a bad decision
now I get Bishop e3 end and within a 5
they have an easier time to enter for
example the night may enter like that
he played Bishop d8 and now I made a
mistake I mean we both were in time
trouble of course but I made a mistake I
should play Bishop d6 keeping an
attention instead I just hacked to the
night and wanted a position that is
totally risk-free we're just definitely
true it's a totally risk-free position
however here black made a mistake he has
only one move that is Bishop to e7 need
to cover this entry square of the White
King this is in all likelihood a draw
you played King 8 however and then all
of a sudden I'm in waiting
he stopped further invasion but now this
was impossible to stop and black reside
yeah I did not use my chances all that
when in this game ultimately at the end
yes I used them but I had a better
middle game before ok this was right
against Bill yharnam
yeah this was a French exchange with
Bishop g4 which can oftentimes turned
out to be pretty dubious
here the issue was he took on f3 and
here's how I decided to play Knight
would be 4 and this was one of those
cases where black was like dashing out
the opening and I don't know why exactly
the first moment the first time he got
to think about and move was when he was
already lost now I can just take on d5
and I'm better I mean I went is better
anyway but this is just winning a big
pawn
got this check me and here saw that
Bishop b2 is a very simple win and he
took on b2 which is not the toughest
move but yeah what can you do is just
pretty awful check you have to play c6
down King him so immediate mate played
c6 and here we have a simple solution
biggest sacrifice and castle and the
resulting attack is totally unstoppable
yeah the King is quite ridiculous on his
7 look everyone is just so strong after
this routine one black resigned his mate
its next move King here looking a
checkmate so very uneven match ok we had
to this game against are they are they
miss mine
yeah yeah I remember
towards the Sicilian was who need more
where I got a good center control here I
already like to watch not because whites
players who is in 93 get the bishop out
enjoy the space but he played Quinta 7
which is an odd decision after Knight c3
you immediately faced with those
potential night jumps in six most played
weakening of the position of Bishop f4
a6 rook c1 it's a fantastic position a
White has got everything developed
nicely and black is not yet close to
cancelling he tried a five after which I
took em played night b5 and this is
quite clearly winning the house and you
winning the rook or whatever
it's just not going to hold we played to
cling to c6 which was inaudible so I
took it and I was just totally winning
it's important to see that in a position
like this as snow is set up like g6
makes more sense when white is already
committed to d4
here after C 3 and D for the black piece
placement it's not really designed to
put any pressure on the center I'm not
saying it's terrible but it's difficult
to handle it's much easier if you get a
clearer grip on the center so I'm very
happy and then there was this game black
against shootin ik
yeah we got this position and here was
quite optimistic because the dark
squares are very weak on the white side
f4 is ready for and we have possible
ways to get the knight to invade and
this is in fact what happened I stopped
a Queen side play and now we don't the
night
yeah f6 this is a more than awaiting
move it prepares Bishop back ninety six
ninety four and white has no active play
I managed to get all of that in and I
was very happy now I mean this is a
fantastic position you have the better
structure you've got pawns that you
attack and White has no play yeah
Indian in the game we had removed some
trades and I managed to pick up
one-by-one
some material and this this ending was
extremely favorable for black and I
managed to win it quite quite quickly so
then we had this position where under
this game where I was black yeah there
was a funny one where yeah white somehow
blitzed out and then the first movie was
thinking about it was too late
a3 yeah this is an odd variation this is
a three line what is basically saying
like okay now it's your turn
do something that helps you and some
things don't really help for example a
move like Bishop c5 is played not so off
because of this sacrifice a common idea
and why it is probably a bit better you
also have a hard time to just say okay I
can do the same because here this is
quite favorable for
is it discouraged for nights where this
move is just not playable so you cannot
just copy me
so at the end of the day I played define
which is the most logical month probably
and now white went Bishop b5 that leads
to funny complications I take with the
knight on e4 and now white went to Queen
to e2 most interesting is 95 after which
I recommend to play Queen to f6 25 is
also playable it's super sharp of course
okay well you play Queen to d2 I played
Queen to b6 I know all that stuff from
colors reversed if you play the Scotch
for Knights you can get the same
position with colors reversed here White
has an extra move III just really helped
so we got this
and here White has to be quite careful
and probably has to play in slowish move
like d3 but white without thinking all
that much grabbed upon even after queen
g6 is already in bad shape really bad
shape the white position is actually
worse than it looks
you currently quite what they see that
I'm threatening here and threaten you to
take the night you played Queen to c3
more natural movers probably this but
after Bishop d6 have an excellent
position for example after the trade the
edge file is open and black has a
fantastic attack he played Queen c3 and
in fact I remembered now on the best
move for my analysis back then form the
reversed color scenario the move Queen
sorry rook to d5 is immensely strong
black wants to play Bishop d6 rook h5
and playful mate and this is
fantastically strong I remember when the
engine gave that with colors reversed
how shocked I was that this is a total
winner so I remember that move we played
g3 now I mean white is already lost
effectively
g3 I just played to rook c5 we went
Bishop d6 intending p8 yeah he played c3
which was you know just ignoring
everything and after rupee aides
resigned look at the Queen it doesn't
have any useful squares yeah it also has
to sort come an f3 so white I am
resigned to him he just loses the house
very clean win okay I had white in this
game yeah this was another opening
disaster played to score three nights
and after Bishop c5 I was able to play
that pseudo sacrifice which is
comfortable for white but after Bishop
takes d4 I'm even not I mean better than
just by a little bit it's it's really a
great position I can easily develop and
black has problems c5 I didn't get I
just take the pawn and here I'm ready
for look at Monaco and well it was a
total disaster and he resigned I
wouldn't a book on h8 and everything
yeah this is some very commonly seen
variation Bishop c5 I'm always surprised
because that sacrifice of pseudo
sacrifice only five or six second nature
to any 45 play of it people still
stumble into that frequently okay this
game
[Music]
yeah okay I remember there was a pulse
defense when black played c5 I took it
and now Queen a5 is played and the best
move we need five of course it takes my
pawn after Bishop d3 pawn takes Bishop
d2 I think white is a bit better I'm
threatening those moves but it's nothing
special here ever recaptured which
surprised me because I'm winning the c5
one and there is not a big compensation
at all I decided to actually give up the
bishop at this moment because after 85
and Bishop d3 I get this enormous fee
for square the bishop b7 Bishop before
take take White's position is basically
winning and the way it turned out and
wonders quite easily it's just like it's
not just a pawn but also the way the
pieces are position both nights yeah
nice night only for in particular and
the : c3 is covering d4 for the rest of
the game yeah I managed to win this
technical part of the game quite easily
ok then I had black him yeah there was
an interesting game actually that's
switch sides it was a king's indian I
play the King's Indian for a change and
he played the Samish I went in a 6b
setup and later played 2 to play c5 and
I was very surprised to see that my b5
for sacrifice wasn't all that great the
engine actually wants me to play this
month in order to threaten to take and
play 95 and in fact and the replies are
not all that satisfactory because the
move like b3 can be very nicely answered
by b5 if you play the Kings onion and
you play in setups with c5 those banquet
movers are quite
yeah I played b5 however and went from
one sacrifice and here I don't have
enough compensation if he goes b3 it's
very questionable if I have enough very
likely that's not the case now in the
game I managed to get some vanquish type
of compensation you cannot easily play
e5 as I am on d5 and after.look anyone
and c4 my counter play was yeah getting
getting momentum he took it would be two
very active pieces and in fact I managed
to invade here quite quite quickly and
White has huge coordination issues I
want material soon after and withered
the game there was nothing spectacular
happening afterwards and then why the
against jugador B's ano that was a funny
game he played the la cartes with Bishop
g4 I think they should be too and he
blitzed out g6 and like everything it
was like instant I went 95 he took it
took it Bishop g7 he had used like one
minute at this one and a couple of
seconds at this point and of course I'm
already totally winning
between the cleanest one which I missed
is Queen f3 this is just a total like
yes sorry here it's a double attack and
I'm winning the might I did not play it
because I wanted to moves earlier I was
seeing that he 6 is also very strong and
that did not really look again I just
played it 6 it makes a lot of sense the
the LightSquared bishop is gone so we're
taking on that
complex will be very very dangerous if
he moves the airport now not have seven
we win the exchange and yeah I maintain
the nice position he canceled
I took it you can educate and now
important not waste time with anything
just go for made age for outplayed 96
and h5 you can do that at this moment I
already saw that after 94 86 I can
sacrifice the Queen here the Queen
cannot be taken quite obviously because
of the maid he played h6 and here I have
96 which is quite cute he took the Queen
and Bishop takes h6 and he resigned
there is no way to stop the mate I'm
threatening Bishop takes g7 double-check
and made in black simply has no defense
he can give that but this is going to be
a maiden tours yeah I'm quite happy
that's a funny little miniature
miniature win ok um the next one here I
had black and oh yeah that was a
fantastically played game by Mohammed we
had an Italian game the 386 Knight c3
played on a very conservative line and I
made a mistaken and not a huge one but
still I don't like Knight f6 here all
that much because after Bishop g5 I
think white in fact white has chances
for a slight advantage it's not much but
this is what they usually do and I think
white might be marginally better and the
move that I play here normally is h6
just wait for one move in then go Knight
f6 however I confuse things and I played
a6 first and he went Knight g5 and this
is
fact quite an annoyance nine age six I'm
forced basically he played aged three
and I managed to get rid of this
suspicion of something to take and here
I should probably cancel and be okay I
played I have six so ever check King
here and 93 I was actually thinking that
the whole action man white does not
really do all that much because the
Queen is actually not having many
squares which is true it only has h4
castle to g6 and here you really shocked
me a little bit by just playing this and
Queen h4 I mean I was shocked by the
speed you just like push playing that
because it is a very very committed
decision it all is kind of it's it's a
bit looser I'm attacking this which is
barely covered by the Queen I have g5
after which there's only one square on
edge five but it turns out computer
editor shows this is just not much I
played it should be six okay he went
back to e3 took it changes seven okay f2
and here this position is totally okay
for me I just have to avoid what I do
and the means that I played was really
really punished very hot I played f5 and
I wanted to solve the issues immediately
not sitting on and wheatish porn for a
long time somebody get rid of it but I'm
opening up the position in an untimely
fashion here I'm already basically lost
Nachi five is very strong that it was
very strong as ideas you know a tiara
invasion time it's beyond saving you
cannot save it now g8 I tried but he
smashed on g6 and I actually allowed the
mate yeah
there was just like being getting a big
hammer down on your head the fantastic
fantastic play I don't know he just
killed me okay I had a black game
against Lewis
we shall yeah that was some what was
that game like yeah okay that was fairly
it wasn't a nuvaring game and we got an
ending got this ending which if anybody
is better
it must be black yeah the night is the
more flexible piece white at best can
try to take d6 with the bishop and it's
easily covered still the whole thing in
the whole position is very closed so
it's very difficult to win however in
the game white played upon and I
responded with b6 probably I shouldn't
have done that but it would be difficult
to win anyhow in the game but something
funny happened right we were moving back
and forth and so nothing much happens
but now we played Bishop d8 and after
Knight is six it's funny this Bishop is
lost if he goes we should be seven I
have King c6 King D 7 and when do you go
ok K sorry this it's not lost he can do
it should be six with 90 M 93 and
picking up everything we win quite
easily also if I do this this is suits
worn it has no square and the King it's
an amazing position somehow yeah you can
try deform it take take take is going to
win very easily yeah he went to h4 and
after g5 the bishop strapped so yeah you
have to be persistent in the
endings sometimes even simplified
positions can give some give some hope
then this one against Masood yeah there
was a complicated position after a weird
opening let me see what is a good time
to jump in and we had an ending I would
like to look at the ending a bit he
played a five I went 84 and when you see
that this is probably just going to be a
draw I was surprised that in this
particular position he did not play
simply b6 after moves like that I think
it's just totally equal he tried b5
after which I win their porn and he gets
h3 but I felt this is a trade that is
rather favorable for me as I have a free
a pawn it's a pesum and black does not
have any and I'm going to get maybe the
Sun yeah I played 94 and when Bishop f6
and now he surprised me by playing
Bishop at 8 and this after 95 is very
nice for white black does not really
have a great square
however he chose the worst square giving
me the bishop and he resigned he should
have gone to c7 instead after which you
move like 90 of 7 it's going to be a bit
better for me because those pawns are
weak but it's not a decisive factor yet
okay in the game he played this and
blunder to third the bishop then we had
this game against Karen here like let me
have a look hyah this was interesting it
was a fairly unspectacular game got this
endgame position which is just basically
about equal but there was an interesting
situation
this and in this position he absolutely
has to move this bishop away
Bishop f3 King f3 yeah the king of three
is actually okay I'm sorry King of three
is okay okay I took and now he has to
take with a king he took with the night
and this is a funny one because after
Bishop c6 he's in a deadly self-penned
yeah now if he moves the King I will
take it
oops so I will take it so he has to play
the F pawn in the game it took after f5
I have the simple move e5 and he's
running out of moves only it's good it's
really quite quite funny I get this
after the capture I play King to six and
again it suits one here check and just a
waiting move and I'm winning this next
using that they're deadly pinned that
was there was nice basically when out of
the blue
yeah so there was a quick quick run
through the thirty games I think this
makes more sense then uploading thirty
games without anything and adding later
editing the videos and it's just a
stretch so I think this at least got you
got something out of the the thirty
games and I will continue to record the
Blitz videos it's a bit of a shame you
know I'm leaving for my vacation in two
weeks and what I wanted to do is I
wanted to have four basically most of
the time of that vacation basically pre
uploaded so I don't have to record
anything at my place during the vacation
so I'm not going to be able probably to
do to do that but I will still be able
to make a couple of videos maybe even
while I'm away
thanks a lot for watching this guys bye
bye